les chéris déjà ils sont tous déguisés
ce soir sachez-le pour mardi gras et je
vais vous demander d'accueillir le
premier d'aiguiser c'est mon ami maxime
galy maxime galy je ne suis pas qu'il
dit il je suis bruce lee merci mais toi
là parce qu'un programme qui joue avec
des zoonoses à l'équipe et on va
peut-être grosse rigolade aujourd'hui
les chéris je vais demander d'accueillir
isabelle morini bosc
elle met du temps où c'était où c'est le
pourboire chambres 35 même si je inocule
de joie joie géraldine maillet eddy
khaldi walk la comédie les voitures et
moi c'est pas parce que j'adore on a
quelques quêtes avec doukkali kelly va
nous venir regarder
[Applaudissements]
mon jeu super multi boutiques ça me file
père bien aimé ça me donne envie
franchement la pesanteur alors justement
tient dans quel but 10 - vous
souhaiteriez vous voir votre partenaire
déguisés pour pimenter votre vie
sexuelle avec partenaires en cendrillon
cendrillon comme ça à minuit elle
disparaîtrait
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas du courbet ça non ça c'est pas
du lit on à jean michel maire j'ai
toujours pas compris à quoi les
télévisée si vous pouviez nous dire chez
moi
[Rires]
singh espère donc non ça pas compte des
vols alors c'est qui les bêtes ont chaud
sommet comme à la prod au séminaire du
bled j'ai des babouches heures des cas
vous êtes toujours aussi drôle c'est
qu'il faut soit votre accoutrement merci
merci beaucoup et nous avons avec nous
bouder qui est avec nous
[Musique]
on rêve à poil mieux ça c est pourquoi
en fait pourquoi une trace à l'ayroule
ou perdre l exemple un article de
pompadour ont marqué leur balance
commerciale eymétois la barre rocheuse
géraldine will et maxime
on est là à deux années de plus en plus
droit alors vous commencez géraldine et
maxime alors de 1 2 3 et vous voulez
vous passer l'offre d'accord poêlée de
alors être ben salah al est honteux
passant dans deux en deux temps de bush
et ben et moi c'est comme valérie mon
mari mon n'aime pas beaucoup les
déguisements donc un soir je dis bah
écoute en tenue d'eve
c'est ton meilleur déguisement est ce
qu'il apporte toujours un pic en pyjama
et pédant tout c'est un tout nu soft
avait les chats que les chemins les
chats tous qu'il s'agite équipe en maïs
haute non et donc il ya un des deux
chats qui a sauté le chartreux il a
sauté dans la rue
preuve qu'il n'y avait pas d'érection
n'ont pas encore là tout ce qui pour moi
c'est vrai il acquit la griffe et le
dise il est le chat a griffé a griffé au
bon endroit et donc on s'est dit que
l'épreuve technique c'était pas pour
nous faut dès qu'on se cantonne à
l'essentiel ah ouais je l'accomplis
kelly silence qui attrapent temps de
tourner allez assez bon
2 c'est bon attention vous mordez temps
sur mon banc de loi voilà trois c'est
moi
jean jouzel battu boxing et nathan brock
n145 son panier ça 9 dur ce propos si ta
connerie ils ont réussi à 8h30 à les
attentions ces partis ont certes rotois
gilou la marquise et magnifique face et
on attend la deuxième
voilà qui va se taper jugnot casser un
oeuf
j'ai pas mal à la rocade ou faire la ola
bravo à vous il est content
[Applaudissements]
bisous bisous fait chaud la pousse
bisous il a dû l'autre
[Rires]